bonjour à tous quelle grande classe je
parle de vous bien sûr je me présente je
suis votre nouveau professeur de
génétique et c'est moi qui vais vous
faire cours de biologie moléculaire
dès le semestre prochain alors vous
attendez sans doute à ce que je vous
fasse cours classiquement peut-être
l'attendait vous peut-être est-ce votre
seule raison d'être ici dans cette belle
classe de mon université
je vous vois déjà le premier rang je
remarque au premier rang les meilleurs
d'entre vous les bons au milieu les
moyens et au fond sans doute ceux qui
aiment moins la génétique car j'imagine
que dans d'autres cours en anglais ou en
mathématiques
vous disposez différemment donc je peux
vous faire court de manière classique et
ça je sais le faire
non seulement je sais le faire mais
j'aime le faire je pourrais bien sûr
vous faire cours des heures et des
heures vous expliquer comment les
molécules fonctionnent les chromosomes
les enzymes vous abreuver de ma science
vous envoyer 100 % de mes connaissances
et vous demander d'en retenir le maximum
d'assimiler d'ingurgiter d'ingurgiter et
chez vous de travailler travailler sans
cesse de manière à ce que si je vous
interroge en cours vous soyez capable de
répondre à mes questions et d'avoir de
bonnes notes
je vois dans vos regards que c'est
exactement ce que vous attendez ou alors
peut-être que certains d'entre vous se
disent pourquoi nous faudrait-il pas une
classe inverser la classe à verser
quelque chose de d'incroyables la casse
a versé c'est très simple on fait le
cours à la maison et on fait les devoirs
en classe
c'est assez facile je vous donne des
livres je vous donne des sites internet
je vous donne des cd rom et puis vous
travaillez chez vous ou à plusieurs en
bibliothèque
et quand vous venez en cours nous
faisons les devoirs je suis votre grand
frère votre père ou autre et je vous
aide vous me posez des questions et
j'essaye de vous aider à comprendre le
cours que vous avez travaillé par
vous-même cours académiques classe
inversé où est la différence
j'ai lu récemment dans un article cette
semaine d'ailleurs une interview d'un de
mes collègues professeurs à paris qui
disait que aujourd'hui si louis pasteur
revenez sur terre est débarqué dans un
laboratoire pour découvrir la recherche
il serait beaucoup plus surpris que
jules ferry rentrant dans une classe
alors moi ce que je vous propose
puisque vous êtes tous là en cours et à
l'heure c'est de faire quelque chose de
vraiment poussé je vous propose la
classe renversé c'est à dire en d'autres
termes le do it yourself
le principe était simple très simple
vous faites tout et je ne fais rien donc
vous allez faire vous même mais chers
élèves les cours
vous allez rédiger les chapitres faire
les plans construire les chapitres
voulait distribuer les produire les
apprendre et même rédigé les questions
les barèmes poser les interrogations
organisé tout même l'examen et moi je ne
sais rien je vous regarde
alors bien sûr je vois déjà des regard
affolé sans doute ceux plus au premier
plan dans les premiers rangs
donc je vais vous aider je vous propose
une méthodologie je vais vous répartir
en équipe
je vais vous répartir en groupe dont je
ferai le casting moi même avec des
collègues qui vous connaissent bien de
manière à mettre dans chaque équipe
des bons élèves en génétique des élèves
moyens et des élèves qui n'aime pas trop
cette matière et puis vous allez vous
organisez vous distribuer les
responsabilités pour l'un sera organisé
le travail pour les autres
rédiger les textes pour d'autres aller
chercher des documents et donc nous
allons transformer cette classe en une
sorte d'entreprise avec des équipes qui
vont travailler ensemble c'est changer
la construction des connaissances
je vous proposerai aussi d'interagir
entre équipes avec une méthode que l'on
a inventé qui est celle des tables au
tournant une méthode extraordinaire au
lieu d'écrire sur un tableau vert au
lieu d'écrire sur les murs nous écrirons
sur des tableaux avec des roulettes
ce qui vous permettra pour chacun
d'entre vous de répondre à des questions
de faire des schémas d'échanger des
informations et moi toutes les cinq
minutes je vous demanderai de tourner de
changer tableaux et de continuer le
travail commencé par un autre et de
compléter ainsi vos connaissances au
bout de trois ou quatre rotations nous
aurons suffisamment de matériel pour
pouvoir travailler ensemble sur celui
qui conviendra le mieux et je pourrais
vous expliquer à ce moment là les rares
choses que vous n'ayez pas compris par
vous même puisque la meilleure façon
d'apprendre et d'enseigner et bien
changeons les rôles vous allez tous
devenir professeur et je suis le seul
élève avoue l'estrade à moi la chaise et
la table donc je propose que vous
fassiez cours que vous m'expliquer les
chapitres et moi je vous poserai des
questions des questions de candide
parfois des questions réelles parce que
je comprendrais pas du tout ce que vous
m'expliquez parfois d'autres questions
un peu plus travailler sachant que vous
avez peut-être une lacune dans
l'explication que vous êtes en train de
me faire et puis puisque vous devenez
les professeurs tout le monde est
professeur et que je suis le seul élève
et bien vous allez menotté donc vous
allez surveiller mon niveau et être
attentif de manière à vérifier que moi
je bénéficie bien des enseignements donc
pour moi les interrogations surprises le
matin à 8 heures
pour moi les qcm pour moi les petites
questions
vous êtes libre vous pouvez m'interroger
en me permettant d'avoir accès aux
documents sans document vous pouvez
aussi et j'espère bien me donner des
devoirs il n'ya plus que moi qui rentre
à la maison avec des devoirs dans mon
cartable des devoirs et le week-end au
lieu de corriger vos copies je ferai mes
devoirs
le cours suivant charge à vous de
corriger les copies de m'expliquer là où
j'ai fait des fautes
et puis de me faire progresser alors
voilà mes chers élèves puisque je vous
ai devant moi et que je vous ai proposé
cette méthode
j'aimerais bien savoir en vous posant
une question et je vais vous la poser
maintenant
il suffira de lever la main qui parmi
vous est d'accord pour vivre cette
expérience avec moi pendant ce cours de
biologie moléculaire extraordinaire vous
répondez à la même question que celle
que j'ai posée à mes élèves
sauf que j'aurais demandé par écrit de
manière à ce qu'il ne s'inflige ans pas
et ils m'ont répondu dès l'entrée la
présentation à 80 90 % qu'ils étaient
volontaires pour faire l'expérience
eh bien nous l'avons fait donc depuis
deux ans cette expérience existe secours
de classe renversé existe à l'université
dans laquelle je travaille et dans ma
salle de classe qui est très grande
avec des tables roulante avec des
tableaux les élèves les étudiants
répartis en équipes travaillent dans des
business unit ils produisent les cours
ils écrivent ils échangent il les publie
sur des plateformes
ils peuvent les lire de chez eux je peux
y avoir accès je travaille avec eux à
distance et en présentiel
en fait la classe de jules ferry et
transformé en fablab un laboratoire de
fabrication
ils ne sont plus noté en connaissance je
ne fais pas d'interrogation puisque ce
sont eux les professeurs par contre je
vais noter leurs compétences quelles
sont leurs compétences leur capacité à
s'organiser entre eux les bons élèves
est dans les moins bons
leurs compétences à respecter les délais
comme dans une entreprise et donc dans
chaque équipe il ya quelqu'un qui
vérifie que les cours sont publiés en
temps et en heure leur compétence à me
poser des questions le professeur que
j'étais devient directeur général se
promène dans son entreprise et passe
d'une business unit à une autre en
demandant si tout se passe bien
et lorsqu'il ya des questions et des
problèmes je peux vous assurer que tous
les étudiants sont attentifs
je n'ai qu'à en capter 5 ou 6 ceux qui
ont le problème les autres continuent le
travail
cette classe transformée en entreprise
à mon avis sur prendrai vraiment jules
ferry peut être un peu moins
d'autres personnages de son époque mais
au moins lui alors s'il fallait retenir
trois observations s'il fallait retenir
seulement trois choses de cette
expérience qui a lieu en ce moment
puisqu'elle se continue la première
d'entre elles est au niveau des
étudiants quel est le comportement des
étudiants comment ont-ils vécu cette
expérience
à la fin de chaque cours et je ne les
lâchent jamais sans leur poser des
questions les cinq dernières minutes à
la fin de chaque cours je leur demande
de répondre à des questions par exemple
dans l'exercice de ce matin sur les
tables au tournant qu'avez vous aimé
quels sont les points que vous n'avez
pas aimé donnez-moi trois adjectifs
positif donnez-moi trois adjectifs
négatif je les oblige à me donner des
points positifs et des points négatifs
ce qui me permet à la fin d'avoir des
regards sur les signaux faibles
l'un des étudiants en me disant une fois
moi j'ai une idée des points positifs
mais j'ai du mal à trouver trois points
négatifs
eh bien tu cherches sinon une sorte de
la classe il faut être en capacité à
répondre à la demande de son directeur
général
ça c'est le point positif un autre point
positif du point de vue des étudiants
c'est que les bons élèves trouvent de
nouvelles capacités de nouveau plaisir à
aider des étudiants moins bon alors que
les étudiants moins bons qu'ils
n'avaient aucune chance de se faire
remarquer en génétique sont souvent les
meilleurs pour aller chercher de
l'information sur internet pour trouver
quelques fois les meilleurs films les
meilleures illustrations mais sont pas
capables en discernement de repérer les
documents qui seront les mieux pour être
mis dans le court donc ça c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant
tout ne fonctionne pas très bien le seul
problème que j'ai avec mes étudiants
ce sont les premiers de la classe les
premiers de la classe qui ont l'habitude
d'écrire d'apprendre de noter ceux là
ont beaucoup de difficultés mais on s'en
sort avec la discussion
le deuxième point d'observation c'est
l'impact sont les professeurs bien
figurez vous que la classe est ouverte
de début du cours jusqu'à la fin toutes
les portes sont ouvertes
les horaires des cours sont indiquées
sur internet sont indiquées dans
l'université
chacun peut venir donc j'ai parfois 40
étudiants 5 ou 6 profs qui viennent pas
forcément de biologie des professeurs de
mathématiques des professeurs d'autres
matières qui se met au milieu de mes
élèves qui s'installe en classe qui
discute avec mes étudiants parfois j'ai
un prof d'informatique qui aide un
groupe à trouver des informations et
donc nous avons créé une communauté de
hackers pédagogique de manière à
diffuser cette méthodologie dans
d'autres matières de manière à
contaminer positivement les collègues
est donc aujourd'hui nous faisons des
protocoles de ce type là en droit des
affaires en économie en marketing et
même en sciences humaines et sociales
dernière observation et c'est sans doute
celle qui va vous surprendre le plus en
tout cas c'est celle qui m'a le plus
surpris des étudiants les enseignants
le changement de posture se comporter
différemment voilà de l'innovation
pédagogique mais la troisième catégorie
de personnes qui ont été très surprise
ce sont les entreprises les chefs
d'entreprise les directeurs généraux
mais vrai les directeurs de ressources
humaines parce que tout ce que nous
faisons dans cette classe pour renverser
et publiée sur internet
donc nous avons un blog et nous publions
nos méthodologies nous publions les
notes quand je suis noter mes notes
apparaissent sur internet
une fois un professeur de marseille
m'envoyer un mail en me disant vous avez
8 sur 20 est normalement ces neuf il
vous oubliez un point donc je suis
rentré je suis rentré dans la classe en
disant il ya un problème
vous m'avez oublié un point pour qui je
passe au vu de tous les internautes
les entreprises les entreprises qui
s'intéressent à l'innovation qui
s'intéressent à la créativité cannot
entre des mots clés et tombe sur
l'expérience d'un prof un peu bizarre
qui fait ce genre d'expérience eh bien
nous sommes contactés et nous
travaillons avec ces entreprises parce
qu'elle se pose la question de
l'innovation
qu'est-ce que l'innovation comment
peut-on pousser l'innovation pédagogique
aussi loin en fait l'innovation
c'est le fruit de la créativité il faut
être créatif
si vous êtes créatif individuellement ou
en intelligence collective comme dans
l'exemple des tables au tournant si vous
êtes créatif et que vous avez de
nouvelles idées il va falloir les
expérimentés faire des prototypes et
donc la créativité elle seule ne suffit
pas vous faites des prototypes des
expérimentations c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons dans la classe renversé
nous expérimentons nous avons des succès
nous avons des échecs parfois et même
souvent et quand il ya des problèmes les
étudiants se réunissent autour de moi et
on résout les problèmes ensemble de la
créativité au prototypage on arrive à
l'innovation
c'est un peu comme si vous étiez sur la
canopée le sommet d'une forêt
amazonienne ou la biodiversité la plus
intéressante et je dis que cette
biodiversité cette innovation n'a de
sens que si vous l'a ancrée vous
l'articuler sur des piliers fondamentaux
donc je continue à faire cours
normalement je continue à faire des
cours classiques et lorsque nous
travaillons avec des entreprises pour
partager nos expériences en terme
d'innovation et bien nous disons aux
chefs d'entreprise ne cassez pas tout
créer des espaces de créativité et
d'innovation inventer des modèles
renverser un verset du do it yourself et
entraînée sur des piliers solides qui
font la réussite depuis toujours de
votre entreprise
donc le vrai challenge de l'innovation
n'est pas de faire des choses nouvelles
le sud pas du tout innovants si je fais
juste un cours inversée ce qui est un
challenge ces deux articuler ce qui est
nouveau à ce qui est ancien et c'est là
que l'on s'y retrouve
enfin pour terminer parce que j'ai des
devoirs à faire ce soir et que lundi ils
m'attendent pour les corrections
je voudrais vous dire que si un jour un
matin dans quelques semaines vous
promener devant mon université ou devant
une autre école
regardez bien les étudiants qui sortent
des stations de métro regardez les bien
sortir des bus regardez les bien se
diriger vers l'université ouvert l'école
et rien à leur allure rien à la façon
dont ils se déplacent peut-être que vous
vous direz que l'un d'entre eux ce matin
à 8 heures où cet après midi à peut-être
un cours renversé avec un prof
renversant je vous remercie